[Musique]
bonjour monsieur violon de martinique
1ère radio candidat à la législative
dans le centre atlantique vous briguer
un mandat de député est élu
vous travaillez forcément sous le regard
de des présidentiables que nous avons vu
hier soir lors du débat de ce second
tour de la présidentielle
ce que vous avez vu hier soir philippe
edmond-mariette ce que vous avez vu ça
donne vraiment envie d'y aller encore
dans l'arène politique plus que jamais
j'ai reçu tout regarder cette nuit
puisque au moment du débat je
travaillais après j'étais sur le terrain
dans une réunion avec des militants et
des habitants d'une région de la
circonscription mais j'ai trouvé le
niveau du débat relativement faible on
était à la limite tout prenne une
insulte par moment et ça nous impose une
obligation de vigilance
demain tous ceux qui seront les
parlementaires de martinique quel que
soit celui ou celle qui sera élue
dimanche pousserait ce sera une usine à
gaz pour présider gouverner et pour les
députés pour contrôler pour amender pour
être force de proposition absolument
ce qui montre bien qu'il nous faut à
cette fonction là des hommes des femmes
d'expérience compétents des véritables
militants de la cause martiniquaise
car jamais nous n'accepterons que notre
l'identité martiniquaise soit dissolue
vous jouez déjà sur cette carte de
l'expérience puisque cette fonction de
député ou lave exercé entre 2003 et 2007
vous connaissez le job y est retourné à
deux reprises et puis on m'avait
expliqué à l'époque philippe
edmond-mariette que vous vouliez
retrouver votre métier de coeur celui
d'avocat
vous vouliez vous consacrer à votre
famille finalement l'appel de la
politique ce peu comme de la drogue
pas du tout et je n'ai absolument pas la
comparaison dessus viol ton d'abord je
n'ai accordé aucune interview indiquant
que je me retirais de la politique
active
j'ai dit c'est vrai que je reprenais
mais fonctionnera pas si je marquais jeu
marquer une rupture avec la politique
active
mais aujourd'hui quand vous avez un
certain nombre d'amis de militants qui
viennent vous voir qui vous disent
philippe il faut y aller même quand vous
avez cette ambition personnelle à votre
vanité pèse de peu de poids parce qu'en
réalité c'est les lectures de la
circonscription qui choisit oui j'ai le
sentiment aujourd'hui d'avoir un courant
favorable de ses internautes des
lecteurs et des lectrices la
circonscription qui me porte
puisque nous sommes l'entraîneur
philippe edmond mariette quelles sont
ses amis
on dit souvent que ce sont ceux du
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
autour d'alfred marie-jeanne monsieur
viol temps il n'y a pas que seulement
mes amis sont sur le territoire du fret
déjà rédigé niall déjà pour eux il ya
beaucoup de mime qui vous demande d'y
aller alors vous savez moi je vois
beaucoup plus large
il ya beaucoup de marins et et manon
déjà pour ça il ya beaucoup nous aurions
nous kg mars tandis qu'elle me demande
d'y aller et qu'il y ait parmi eux un
certain nombre de militants du mime
comme d'autres formations politiques
oui ça me paraît tout à fait normal
parce que ce sont des hommes et des
femmes qui ont conscience de ce qu
aujourd'hui compte tenu justement de ce
que vous venez de rappeler sur votre
question introductive par rapport à ceux
qui demain celui ou celle de main qui
demain ce cas la tête de notre grille
plus de la république française
incontestablement nous avons besoin
d'hommes ou de femmes élues martinique
est compétent qu'il ne soit pas là pour
compter leurs voix principale reconnaît
bien ils soient véritablement posture de
porter haut la voix martinique on va
battre autour du pot dans cette
circonscription du candidat du rpt à
josette manin ancien président du
conseil général et soldates de bâtir le
pays martinique dont vous avez été
membre
parmi ces dandys candidat également de
l'opposition fabrice du nom soutenu
personnellement par alfred marie jeanne
vous comprenez l'équation vous comprenez
les questionnements de tous de tous les
auditeurs qui nous écoutent oui soutien
d'une radio non je répète encore une
fois pas seulement des hommes et des
femmes qui sont militants du mime et
puis je dépasse mois cette question là
qui n'est que chicane il s'agit pas de
savoir si untel ou untel est soutenu par
x ou par y
je les ai déjà dit mais je le répète si
le simple fait d'avoir l'option
marie-jeanne east permettait d'être
immédiatement élu monsieur viau le temps
qu'on venait avec moi qu'on nous ait eu
à ce moment là beaucoup de mères qui
soit élu à cette fonction là avec cette
couleur production l'option magna
dispose servir jeu à la députation je
crois je crois que ce qui est essentiel
c'est de se poser la question quelle est
ou la femme qui peut être utile à ce job
là pour reprendre le flambeau de
monsieur marie jeanne mais sûr je quitte
à être en capacité de le faire je le dis
avec humilité et modestie mais vous même
la vie rappelé j'ai déjà exercé ces
fonctions là l'expérience que j'ai ma
formation professionnelle jeu presque
envie de dire me prédispose à pouvoir
porter la voix de la martinique dans
l'hémicycle mais c'est pas seulement ça
parce que il ne suffit pas d'être comme
deux êtres que juriste pour prétendre
être que parlementaire il faut
absolument qu'on plus près de la
population
cette population là décident de vous
choisir et de vous apporter leurs
suffrages
mais vous savez ce qu'on reproche aux
parlementaires ici en martinique d'être
souvent absent de peut travailler qui on
voit très peu de retombées sur le
quotidien des martiniquais qu'il se
balade sur le compte de l'état en
prenant l'avion de se promener dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée nationale
est ce que quelque part vous en avez
conscience et que vous savez qu'il
faudra quand même rétablir l'image de
marque de la fonction de député
wolton là franchement edmond mariette il
faut il faut il faut ce type d'image la
journaliste de cette qualité-là tordre
le cou à ça c'est comme les gens qui
disent martinique première a les moyens
de l'état aurait pu gagner production le
carré non ça suffit les hommes et les
femmes pouvaient avoir un inventaire
travers eux les hommes et les femmes qui
sont parlementaires travaillent en tout
cas moi j'ai fait la démonstration s'est
passé vient y voit ici les quatre camps
où j'étais là parce qu'il manquait à
l'époque singulièrement de moyens de
communication aujourd'hui avec
l'avènement des réseaux sociaux
je pense que le parlementaire ce cas en
capacité de bien montrer pour peu qu'ils
un blog pour peu qu il un moyen de
communication modernes qu'il montre son
application
moi moi j'ai soulevé quand j'étais
parlementaire trois questions
la première celle du chlordécone tout le
monde s'en souvient même si je ne suis
pas satisfait des réponses qui ont été
apportées en totalité
d'ailleurs je compte y revenir le
deuxième problème celui du développement
économique à l'époque l'outil qu'on
utilisait ces tel véhicule de la
défiscalisation
je suis monté au créneau pour défendre
cette idée là et puis la troisième chose
c'était notre jeunesse et l'emploi
et là je n'ai pas été suffisamment
entendu la voix ma voix n'a pas
suffisamment porté faute de relais
aujourd'hui ce que je souhaite c'est pas
être uniquement
lui qui va crier dans un hémicycle this
ne voudra pas du tout mais coûter mais
c'est faire en sorte d'être en capacité
avec diplomatie de réunir les six
parlementaires martiniquais les deux
sénateurs qui vont être que lui en
septembre les quatre parlementaires qui
vont être que lui au mois de juin les
quatre députés pour que nous formions à
ce moment là un vrai groupe associé à un
autre
et pourquoi pas former un groupe de
parlementaires ultramarins
ça nous donnera les moyens d'une plus
grande visibilité je veux que ça donnera
pour une participation au bureau on
retombe dans le monde de oui oui enfin
on va vouloir y croire qu'on peut être
unie à l'extérieur alors qu'ici on se
déchire
monsieur viol ton le monde de oui oui
c'est le monde de nos premiers rêves
quand will we ce petit pantin et dans
une petite voiture tout petit en bois
avec des pédales
ici la gym avec la tête c'est vrai qu'il
demande au lido doline mais ils
s'imaginent demain dans une forme dans
une formule 1
il nous appartient à nous de traduire sa
en actions concrètes et j'ai presque
envie de dire arrêtons de parler
maintenant agissons la martinique en a
besoin
il y a urgence à le faire alors reparler
des actions que vous avez mené une
action prioritaire prioritaire pour vous
aussi par hasard vous êtes élu au mois
de juin
la santé la protection sociale et
singulièrement la question de nos
hôpitaux
en arrivant sur la route très
embouteillé j'écoutais encore votre
reportage sur l'hôpital de trinité il
était concevable qu'on soit dans cette
situation là sur ce dossier j'ai un
certain nombre de personnes qui
m'entourent qui sont des férus qui sont
des professionnels de la santé
moi même j'ai exercé par le passé les
fonctions de président du conseil de
surveillance du centre hospitalier du
lamentin
c'est des questions que je connais
peut-être que pas parfaitement mais que
je vais rajouter je profite d'ailleurs
de votre antenne sur la question de la
santé
très bon coup très rapidement vous faire
un coucou à un ami
cet ami a passé avec moi le bac nous
étions terminal ensemble il s'appelle
camille alexandre dujeux disque est
vraiment une très très bonne santé et
qu'ils reprennent le combat
nous sommes tous avec camille une
dernière question ce sera qui votre
suppliante ma suppléante c'est la vie
scolaire
elle est adjointe au maire du groupe
bert et les membres de cap nau jeune
martiniquaise d'une trentaine d'années
présidente de l'association as poteau
une martiniquaise jean rey
sponsable une jeune ex d'une belle
jeunesse c'est cette image là que j'ai
envie d'offrir aux habitants de la
circonscription merci d'avoir été ce
matin avec nos philippe edmond-mariette
candidat à la législative dans la
circonscription du centre aquatique
bonne chômeurs 6 me suis vu une très
bonne journée à vous auditeurs